Previously, we discussed how to
generate notifications on the phone,
like this here.
And how they're automatically
synchronized over to
the wearable device.
However, you might run into
a situation where you want to generate
a notification on a wearable,
but not on the phone.
This is not possible with the code
that we went through earlier.
The solution to this,
is to create a notification on
the wearable device itself.
If you create it on the wearable
from within the wearable APK,
it will only appear on the wearable.
It is never synchronized
over to the phone.
A notification generated on a wearable
uses exactly the same code as done on
the phone.
You can use all the same code
that you did previously.
I just wanted to point this all out now,
since you did not know
about wearable apps when we
previously discussed notifications.
There are two great samples that you
should refer to in the sample browser.
Synchronized notifications is the first
and notifications is the other.
In synchronized notifications,
let's load that one up.
Input sample and
synchronize notifications.
It's in the wearable project in
notification updateservice.java.
The method we're looking for
is BuildWearableOnlyNotification.
In this method you can see the code
used to make a notification
is exactly the same as
what you've seen before.